vamos a iniciar con una introducción a
los alcances ok los arcanos tienen una
fórmula molecular general que consiste
de n carbonos y si tenemos de carbonos
entonces tendremos 2 cn más dos
hidrógenos ok entonces sólo para asentar
algunas ideas por ejemplo si tenemos un
carbono entonces tendremos c1 y si
tenemos un carbono tendríamos dos por
uno más dos son cuatro verdad entonces
tenemos un ch4 porque generalmente este
uno no se pone verdad y esa y ese
compuesto ya lo hemos visto muchas veces
justamente es el metano verdad tenemos
un carbono y si hacemos su estructura de
puntos
su estructura se ve de esta forma verdad
este es justamente el metano ahora qué
pasaría si por ejemplo tuviéramos dos
carbonos entonces tenemos dos carbonos y
cuántos hidrógenos tendríamos tendríamos
dos por dos que son cuatro más dos son
seis hidrógenos y la estructura de esto
pues sería justamente dos carbonos
unidos y en cada uno de estos solo para
completar el el octeto de cada uno de
estos carbonos pues necesitamos otros
tres hidrógenos verdad entonces
justamente estas son digamos son los
ejemplos más sencillos de alcan los que
tenemos este segundo se llama eta no muy
bien
y de hecho hay millones y millones de
compuestos orgánicos y debemos de tener
alguna especie de una forma lógica para
para nombrarlas verdad así que un
carbono como ya vimos es el metano dos
carbonos es etano y estos nombres están
determinados por lo que se conoce como
el sistema de nomenclatura de upac iupac
se refiere a la unión internacional de
química pura y aplicada y esto por
supuesto en por sus siglas en inglés
verdad y en la química en realidad este
es un montón de químicos tratando de de
juntarse y decir cuáles van a ser los
nombres de estas moléculas de una forma
muy sistemática
así que para el resto de este curso
vamos a enfocarnos en la nomenclatura
iupac para para la nomenclatura para
nombrar más bien moléculas orgánicas así
y en más o menos relieve hecho un
resumen de esta de esta nomenclatura en
esta tabla ok entonces aquí tenemos por
ejemplo el número de carbonos que
aparecen en nuestra cadena de carbonos y
cuál es el prefijo que le corresponde
ahora si nosotros tenemos puros arreglos
lineales entonces se refiere a un alcano
ok entonces por ejemplo si nosotros
tenemos un carbono ya vimos que el
prefijo es met y por lo tanto se llama
metano verdad déjenme ponerlo con otro
color es un
un arcano de un único carbono se le
conoce como metano también ya vimos que
el de dos carbono se le conoce como
metano ahora bien si tenemos tres
carbonos este se conoce como propano y
cuál sería su estructura lineal su
estructura lineal sería algo así verdad
recordemos que cada vértice representa
un carbono y los hidrógenos que están
unidos a él están implícitos ahora si
tenemos cuatro carbonos este sería el
butano verdad de hecho puedes darte
cuenta que la terminación a no es
justamente porque estamos trabajando con
arcanos muy bien entonces el butano su
estructura lineal sería algo así ok
tenemos no ya me pase por uno tenemos
justamente cuatro verdad el penta no
sería el que sigue verdad justamente
tenemos el prefijo pence que se refiere
a cinco carbonos y la terminación a no
que se refiere a que es una cadena
lineal y de hecho todos estos casos son
cadenas lineales de carbonos y así
podríamos seguir nos verdad por ejemplo
tendríamos el hexano
6 átomos de carbono metano para 7 octano
para 8 9 para 9 tendremos no nano y así
de hecho sigue esta lista que aquí he
puesto no decano un decano cuando
tenemos 11 para 12 tenemos a decano tri
decano para 13 y así sucesivamente hasta
que llegamos a 20 que tiene el prefijo
ecos y entonces tendríamos un eco sano
muy bien y de hecho esto este estos
prefijos no sólo son son se aplican para
los arcanos sino también para otro tipo
de grupos funcionales así que es muy
importante memorizar todos estos
prefijos porque de aquí en adelante
vamos a utilizarlos mucho así que ya
hemos hablado bastante sobre cadenas
digamos lineales de arcanos qué pasa si
tenemos algunas ramificaciones en un
arcano justamente como este ejemplo ok
que pasaría aquí entonces lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es identificar cuál es
la cadena más larga que podemos
construir entonces si nos damos cuenta
aquí tenemos
1 2 3 4 5 5 carbono es verdad aquí
justamente déjenme enumerar los este es
el carbono 1 2 3 4 5 verdad es del más
largo porque si yo me fuera para arriba
tendríamos solo 3 y si nos vamos en
digamos de aquí arriba si acá también
tendríamos 5 muy bien entonces el
detalle aquí es que tenemos una
ramificación en el segundo carbono
verdad y es una ramificación que sólo
tiene un carbono a este tipo de
ramificaciones se les conoce como
sustituye entes entonces este es un
sustituye ente verdad y esencialmente es
un grupo es un grupo digamos por ejemplo
este que tiene un único carbono es un
grupo conectado conectado a nuestra
cadena principal
ala
cadena principal y justamente cuando
este grupo que está unido se parece
digamos en cierto sentido a un arcano
entonces se le conoce como un grupo
alquiló ok en este caso es un grupo
alquilo verdad porque no tiene en
enlaces múltiples no tienen nada excepto
carbono e hidrógeno y enlaces sencillos
ahora como éste tiene un único carbono
entonces tenemos que regresarnos a ver
cuál es digamos el nombre que le
corresponde y es justamente meta verdad
entonces este de aquí corresponde a un
grupo metilo que de hecho lado se
suprime cuando vamos a darle nombre pero
ahorita no nos vamos a centrar en los
nombres simplemente vamos a tratar de
identificar cuáles son los sustituye
entes o los grupos al kilo que tenemos
en los distintos ejemplos
entonces si nos damos cuenta aquí
tenemos una cadena principal de 5 átomos
de carbono entonces vamos a tratar de
recordar eso cuando tenemos 5 átomos de
carbono entonces tenemos un pent a nos
verdad venta no este es un pantano
muy bien y como les mencioné en vídeos
posteriores vamos a ver qué pasa o cómo
darle una nomenclatura más formal cuando
tenemos un grupos o grupos sustituye
entes adheridos a una cadena de o más
bien a un arcano
vamos a trabajar otros ejemplos que no
son tan sencillos de hecho se ven un
poco más complicados y aquí tenemos tres
copias de la misma digamos de la
estructura de líneas o de enlace líneas
de esta de una misma molécula ok
entonces vamos a tratar de identificar
todos los grupos sustituye entes que
salen de la cadena principal y por
supuesto primero tenemos que identificar
cuál es la cadena principal entonces
vamos a empezar por aquí digamos tenemos
dos tres si nos vamos por acá arriba
tendríamos cinco verdad y si nos vamos
por abajo tenemos cuatro por ejemplo 5
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5
déjenme ver por aquí
déjenme ponerle a todos estos una línea
más ok solo para que quede el ejemplo
que realmente estoy pensando y que
podamos identificar muy bien de qué
estamos hablando entonces la cadena
principal empieza aquí tendríamos 1 2 3
4 5 6 y podríamos irnos hacia la derecha
o hacia abajo digamos aquí vámonos
hacia la derecha verdad entonces esta
cadena cuántos átomos de carbono tiene y
aquí tendríamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7 entonces
justamente tendríamos una cadena de 7
átomos de carbono y si tratamos de
recordar el 7 corresponde a & entonces
tendríamos un ept a no verdad tenemos el
caso de un ept a no ahora vamos a tratar
de identificar los grupos sustituye
entes que salen de esta cadena principal
de aquí por ejemplo en el segundo átomo
de carbono tenemos
un grupo sustituye ente de un único
carbono entonces este es un grupo metilo
verdad este es un grupo metilo y por
ejemplo en el tercero en el tercer
carbono tenemos un grupo sustituye ente
de dos átomos de carbono aquí están los
dos y para recordar vamos a ver que el
segundo cuando tenemos dos átomos de
carbono corresponde al prefijo es verdad
entonces este es un estilo ese es un
grupo estilo porque todos los grupos
alquiló justamente a heredan esa
terminación y lo verdad
muy bien también tenemos un grupo
sustituyen t aquí en el cuarto carbono
que también consta de dos átomos de
carbono y este entonces es un estilo
verdad vamos a ver qué pasaría si ahora
en vez de irnos hacia digamos hacia la
derecha en esta bifurcación nos vamos
hacia abajo entonces ahora elegimos esta
cadena de aquí ok
esta cadena de aquí nos vamos hacia
abajo y en vez de irnos hacia la derecha
seguimos hacia abajo muy bien entonces
si nuevamente enumeramos tenemos 1 2 3 4
5 6 y 7 carbonos nuevamente esto es un
eta no verdad pero tenemos digamos vamos
a ver qué tipo de ramificaciones tenemos
en el segundo átomo de carbono tenemos
un grupo metilo lo cual coincide con el
caso anterior en el tercero también
tenemos un grupo estilo y en el cuarto
tenemos un grupo estilo entonces si te
das cuenta no importa si nos fuimos a la
derecha o hacia abajo
en realidad obtuvimos la
la molécula es exactamente lo mismo solo
que está acomodado de distinta forma
ahora vámonos al último caso aquí vamos
a irnos en vez de irnos hacia la derecha
en el carbono 3 vamos a ir a irnos hacia
la izquierda porque entonces vámonos
hacia la izquierda ahora y cuántos
átomos de carbono tenemos pues
nuevamente vamos a tener 1 2 3 4 5 6 y 7
átomos de carbono entonces en cualquiera
de estos casos si te das cuenta
obtuvimos lo que es un ept a no pero
aquí el número de ramificaciones cambia
por ejemplo aquí ya no tenemos una
ramificación en el segundo pero sí en el
tercero verdad y es una ramificación un
poco más complicada de hecho tiene tres
átomos de carbono en lo cual corresponde
como una especie de propano pero no está
unido de forma lineal está unido en el
segundo y bueno ya en vídeos posteriores
vamos a entrar en más detalles de cómo
darle nombre a estas cosas
y por supuesto también en el cuarto
átomo de carbono tenemos un una
ramificación de dos átomos de carbono lo
cual es un grupo estilo muy bien aunque
la pregunta adecuada sería cuál de estos
dos casos el de arriba o el de abajo
sería la cndh el adecuado para darle una
nomenclatura según el sistema de upac
así que tenemos dos cadenas de igual
longitud digamos son son cadenas de
siete átomos de carbono pero como como
digamos rompemos el empate para decidir
cuál va a ser el que le va a dar la
nomenclatura y las reglas de iupac
establecen que tenemos que elegir la
cadena principal que tenga el mayor
número de sustituye entes así que en el
primer caso tenemos justamente tres
grupos sustituyen t mientras que en el
segundo tenemos solo dos así que el que
vamos a elegir es el segundo y este es
el que le va a dar nombres según las
reglas de upac
muy bien entonces hasta ahora hemos
trabajado con cadenas lineales vamos a
ver qué pasa si trabajamos con anillos
anillos de carbono que son que son ciclo
alcanos muy bien
por ejemplo este primer caso tenemos un
triángulo entonces quiere decir que
tenemos tres átomos de carbono verdad y
que si por ejemplo los ponemos en su
estructura de enlace línea se vería algo
así verdad de estos tres carbonos unidos
y para completar el octeto tenemos que
poner los hidrógenos restantes por
ejemplo este primero ya tiene dos
enlaces necesita otros dos que son
hidrógenos verdad para este otro
necesita otros dos y para este último
carbono necesita otros dos verdad
entonces esta es la estructura de enlace
en línea y de hecho su fórmula molecular
sería tres átomos de carbono y seis
átomos de hidrógeno y por supuesto ya
podrás darte cuenta que en realidad una
fórmula general para un ciclo al k no es
tener n átomos de carbono y tendremos el
doble de átomos de hidrógeno y eso es
porque de cada uno le salen dos átomos
de hidrógeno verdad y por supuesto éste
un propano porque tiene tres átomos de
carbono entonces vamos a recordar que en
realidad para tres el prefijo es prop
entonces este se llama propano pero éste
está distribuido en un arreglo es
cíclico entonces se va a llamar ciclo
propano muy bien inmediatamente
podríamos pensar qué pasa con este
cuadrado verdad este cuadrado tiene
cuatro átomos de carbono tiene cuatro
átomos de carbono y le corresponde el
prefijo wood así que este es un butano
pero como este en arreglo cíclico es un
ciclo butano ciclo butano
vamos a ver tengo dos ejemplos más aquí
tenemos un pentágono eso quiere decir
que tenemos cinco átomos de carbono
entonces este es un ciclo pentano y el
último caso es quizás el más importante
de todos los ciclo arcanos verdad tiene
seis átomos de carbono y este es el
ciclo hexano verdad corresponde a un
cano en arreglo psíquico con este
cíclico perdón con 6 átomos de carbono
así que esta fue una introducción a los
arcanos ya los ciclos arcanos en los
próximos vídeos vamos a entrar con mayor
detalle en lo que es la nomenclatura